Congrats to greenbook on the best
picture win new in theaters this weekend
Tyler Perry's at Madea family funeral
and Greta what will you see this is your
weekend ticket okay
well you look bad we here cuz your dad
is dead not me coordinating the funeral
I know it's about funerals I don't bear
it a lot of men a lot of them Tyler
Perry returns as Madea and several other
characters in the eleventh and possibly
last installment of the Madea franchise
[Applause]
in this film instead of enjoying the
planned family reunion
the Madea crew finds themselves planning
a funeral oh Lord
we're sorry apparently he was taking
some sort of stimulant we're having some
fun keeping it down this movies for you
if you're a fan of the Tyler Perry Madea
franchise
dark comedies make you laugh or funerals
man what a hoot also out this weekend
Greta in this horror thriller drama
Francis a young independent new to New
York New Yorker returns a purse she
found on the subway so nice she then
befriends the old woman she returned it
to so nice where the candles turns out
the woman Greta is freaking crazy
how exciting I can't do this hey that's
not so nice this movie is for you if you
love creepy thriller movies you're a fan
of Chloe grace Moretz or you're looking
for an excuse to not return things you
find on the streets to the people they
belong to like this wallet that is your
weekend ticket what will you see and
check back next week for Marvel Studios
first female lead superhero movie
[Music]